all right it's 6:00 in the morning and
you know what that means it's amnesia
time and
this is part 9 I think if I don't
remember if I do remember we found this
a little pedal become splash probably
did this a minute ago if you're watching
this oh can I put my hand there yeah
for shame either way I thought it was
gonna explain the story a little quickly
in case someone wishes missed an episode
or whatever this is just how I
understand it and I'm I really don't
understand stories really well so I'm
doing my best here basically we woke up
in this castle
after seeing a cutscene of us walking in
a corridor for some reason and we later
realize that we have erased our memory
drink drinking some sort of ocean that
erase our memory and we left the note
for ourselves saying I might as well
walk in here meanwhile we left the note
to us I was saying that we chose to
forget but we have to kill a man named
Alexander brennenburg I think it's the
will you take us to the inner sanctum it
will definitely take care of the
vertical part of our journey so you have
written an elevator before yes the
Colosseum a Regents Park has been it
takes you to the gallery where you can
view the panorama your this ride my
field it longer and in the other
direction oh I don't want to go there
all right let's see screwing it it's
alright it's an elevator so yeah we have
to kill this man and we haven't seen him
yet confused it's supposed to be any
probably wondering like how am I
supposed tell him if I can't even defend
myself but he's supposed to be like a
young I'm supposed to be honor he's
supposed to be all than weak so
apparently this man has you know I'm
supposed to be mad at him but I don't
remember so if I had to think then I
guess he betrayed me some sort that is
not as well that is
it's not working let's see let's cheat a
little bit
find a way to start ending that power
center we found Aquila
sorry
so that's pretty much what I think about
the story and apparently I've been
exploring in Africa and find some
artifact I haven't seen it yet [ __ ] it's
lagging
some sphere and I assume that has
something to do with with what's
happening this castle
apparently we knew there's gonna
everything that's been breaking down
there has been like holes in the ceiling
and whatever so we knew that this shadow
was coming and there's a shadow hunting
me
he doesn't like me and I can't fight it
so I need to escape it and that's why
I've been so [ __ ] scared I think
that's what's so scary about this game
that you can't really fight back her
[ __ ] trunk was wrapped in a rope in
rope Locke had been broken by thieves he
assumed he wondered if anything had been
left considering all the hands it had
passed down here and it's a creepin
setting we don't have much oil left at
all this is really scary really scary
what is this
what is going on here
all right for this [ __ ] this is really
scary
Oh
I don't like open spaces like this who
left it sir
is you la monster oh I'm out of oil
isn't that great
I'm gonna go insane crystal Claire I
never been that before I sit down [ __ ]
the dark I scarce of [ __ ] out of me it's
much easier if you had the lantern must
say that
I gotta use these though I really
oh that helps so much I forgot how scary
this game was for a while I'm pretty
sure I can bump into the monster here
and guess what I don't like that
don't like that at all can't say out
please tell me that's oil No
I hope you guys realize what I'm going
through
[ __ ] hell
putting this 6:00 in the morning with
headphones on is pretty makes a
difference I have to say
that's
focus drill Oh
but I could drill a hole in this
open [ __ ] is in here
it's still crystal clear all right
[ __ ] is this
a lot of stuff though in other drilled
parts
I guess
ah you can never let your guard down in
this game then that's when they will
scare the [ __ ] out of you
primary did you just say that
can I combine these or something
let's check the end this Oh what the
hell is this oh this is rocks
all right
so dark
our notes lots of tender boxes let's
read this alyc regarding explosive
mixture Alexander I prepared the
explosive you need for clearing the
flooded dreams I can't stress enough how
important is that the mixture is handled
with care please try to tell your
featherbrained servants that this before
you go ahead with your plans Oh before
you go ahead with your plans that's how
you read it
Weehoo liquids are not by themself
explosion and should be kept separated
to avoid further mishaps I have ranged
two large vats in the next room for the
ingredients all you need to do is mix
the liquids and you are ready to go
Agrippa all right
and that's what I'm supposed to do why
can't I just pick this up it doesn't
make sense make my life easier but
that's not how this game works is it
how's my sanity slide I take
[ __ ] and I need oil
Wow it was creepy
great please let there be oil thank you
oh that was nice just I like you but
since I have so many tinderboxes oh he
might as well
yeah they're [ __ ] everywhere
Jesus Christ they're friendly
all right so I guess there's nothing
else in here
let's continue
I'm not sure what I'm supposed to do I
guess I'm gonna collect both of those
stuff and
sit I guess
already been in here
hello master
I'm not scared Sam what the [ __ ] am I
kidding all right I think I've been in
all the rooms
I guess these barrels see what it said
I might as well oh there is a handle
there I didn't see that in the dark
rusted shut then what do you do
no use Oh so I have to fix the rest
how do I put the drill together
I need to find all the parts
J parents haven't them I thought I did
that let's check more carefully
be careful all right
Wow the lantern is so nice like it's a
lot
the candles always do the work yes
I would anyone hide it drill the help
came from their tank at least
and this is too so I might as well do
that as well
Beaufighter research
I was up there though nothing
keep hearing stuff
you can lift these I'm confused
monster
hello master
cheeky cheeky
why am I wasting the way
it's gotta be Isis
oh god that's so dark to creep